ethan you talk a little about how you
met seymour but i wonder if you could
tell us about
the genesis of this as a film project i
mean
you met him at a party
did you know at that point i'm going to
make a movie about this guy absolutely
not um i i went
home and
you know googled seymour i was kind of
obsessed i was trying to tell my wife
about this person that i met and but i
googled you too i know i know
because i didn't know who you were i
know so we were we were mutually
googling over you know uh crossing
through the internet
and
one thing that had happened at the
course of the evening is i had
when i heard that
seymour hadn't played in so long in
front of people there was a
a piano at this person's apartment and i
was begging him to play in front of
everybody and he he said that he
wouldn't because of the quality of the
piano right
i mean that was what you said
yeah i know i know it was what was it it
was it wasn't a steinway it was a it was
a bold one yeah and so he wouldn't do it
not against baldwins they were beaut but
i
would have preferred to play on my own
favorite piano well that's what he said
and so he invited me to come to his
house to hear him play if i were a year
later so one year later because
and to be fair i was leaving town and
but there was a lot of reasons why but
one year later we finally got it
together and i came over to his
apartment with um
my then 14 year old daughter
and andrew harvey
another couple friends we all met over
at seymour's house
and seymour played for us
and it was there that i felt uh
that i was sitting in an incredibly
privileged seat
and i was really really moved
and
andrew
harvey who's it who's in the movie when
we walked out he just
i was speaking about how moving it was
and he just kept saying you should make
a documentary about this you should make
a documentary about this and i remember
thinking yes somebody should
um and my first thought was the
filmmakers that i knew who would do a
good job of this because i had no
no part of me thought that i could or
would have any interest in in doing it
but as
some time went by i started thinking
about what a good idea that was you know
what was the original shape of how you
conceived of the party very much exactly
what you see i mean the idea was a
little bit i had enough
we had been emailing each other over the
year and i'd have enough contact with
seymour to
for lack of a better word it was a
little bit about what if you could do
what zen in the art of archery did as a
piece of literature as a
as a as a piece of cinema
if you could explore i didn't want to
make a movie about seymour was born on
wednesday he did this on you know
thursday he did that and like it wasn't
going to be a
biography and this is i hope you don't
mind me telling when i told him this
he that i wanted to make the documentary
he said i can think of you know i forget
you can think of a million musicians
right now that you should make a
documentary i was dumbstruck because you
know what i what andrew said to me
that whether you want to or not we're
making a documentary on your
well i didn't even know what to say
nobody ever made a movie
you know i mean do you know any movie
star who's 88
i just turned 88 on friday
so i was dumbstruck really dumbstruck no
but you know what you i found out what
you did
you had read my books
that's what i did and and
you were struck you you told me what you
were struck with
you you always you said
quite obviously everybody knows that
life influences the way you act right
but it never occurred to you
that your acting could influence your
life
like my playing influences my life i had
never heard that before and i spent my
life around artists you know i did my
first movie when i was 13 i did my first
professional play when i was 12. i spent
my life in rooms with actors and
musicians and writers
you know that's what i've done and
and i've seen so many people
young people middle aged people older
people
get lost
via depression
via insecurity
via pomposity
i mean there's so many ways to get lost
and um it was really wonderful to spend
time with you
uh
because you had dedicated your life to
the arts and you are clearly not lost um
and it felt good to be near you
and uh
so i thought that was a pretty profound
idea to make a movie about and that if
the movie could kind of be about that
teaching
um
about life and art and
and that's why it was important i
thought that seymour actually play in
the movie
you know that
that it was important that it
that you could see the integration and
that it really was possible because
what being in your house in your
apartment listening to you play is
exquisite you know it's just incredible
seymour did do you recall what it was
like when ethan
kind of said this is it we're going to
make this documentary what were your
thoughts uh other than
there were other people more worthy of
having
exactly what ethan said yeah i said well
now why would anyone want to do that
about the likes of me
i know so many more interesting
musicians
but i did discover that he had read my
book he was fascinated
about the fact that
when you have a passion for something
and you work at it
that can integrate your personality
not just it's not just that life
influences
your passion but your passion for an art
form
can influence your life
and that may be true for any discipline
do you you know one of the things that's
interesting i don't
know to what it yeah it did make the
final cut but when you're um
you talked about it more but
i was always fascinated where
when you would do those marches and when
you're in korea
and you were kind of shocked to find
how disciplined your mind was and how
you could do it
and
yes i felt that that was directly
related
to the discipline that i learned from my
art
you have disciplines too look what you
have to do
i mean you're playing macbeth at lincoln
center what an overpowering
responsibility
so mustering
all of you your emotional intellectual
and physical worlds
that has to be a very powerful
integration
so why leave it on the stage
you take it into your life right
speaking about discipline tell us about
how you structured this i mean did you
just begin shooting seymour and his
students and knowing that you were
headed to a final performance to be to
be totally honest with you um
it i'm very happy with how it turned out
i think i don't know if you're allowed
to say that but i'm really happy about
that and
a lot of it was shot from the hip
meaning
i had a gut feeling that there was a
movie here
you know and that there was something
cinematic about seymour and about this
idea but if it weren't for you know greg
and
some of the other we have a wonderful
editor my wife helped produce two and
together
it was a wonder documentary is a very
interesting way to work
you know because we would get together
for a day
shoot for eight or nine hours and then
go back and look at it and then think
about it and i had an idea that getting
seymour to play i'm a member of the
labyrinth theater company and i thought
it might be interesting to get seymour
to play in front of the labyrinth isn't
just actors a lot of them are writers
and dancers and they a lot of them are
they're very involved as in the arts as
a whole thing not just as one discipline
but you know there's some old saying
that you know to really master one art
form you need to be very good at at
least three
you know that that
in in the labyrinth theater kind of
plays with that idea that you're and so
i thought seymour would be uh very good
to speak with that would be a right
setting for who to play for
and that would integrate the story that
we're telling about how music relates to
other arts you know the
what's the mark twain line all art
aspires to be music you know often when
people are editing they talk about the
rhythm when people speak of shakespeare
or sam shepard or tennessee williams
they talk about the the rhythm or the
music or the tonalities you know you
often those those vocabulary words show
up and so
it was a balance of finding out
you know first of all you find out oh
wow seymour and michael kimmelman are
great friends he used to be assumed
michael kimmelman is a great writer
michael kimmelman is a serious music
critic um michael kimmelman oh i gotta
get the two of them talking and and he's
a brilliant pianist and he's a brilliant
pianist i taught him at five well i know
it's in the movie and
i edit that scene for like two years
either um but one of the things that is
so
i
we all have
a lot of you are filmmakers and
there's always things that i'm never
sure if they move an audience but i
remember greg and i in the editing room
when
you and when michael's playing that
mozart piece in your house and you and
you start accompanying him i i
the truth is there's a much longer
version of that and
if the movie could be 14 hours long it
would be in it but it's it moves me to
tears seeing
the two of you people that
know each other intimately and seeing
them communicate with something beyond
words
he was in his 60s right
michael is he isn't he
so imagine i've been teaching him from
five
to sixty
i'm still teaching him
well isn't it amazing
there's of course there's no end
schumann is the one that said there's no
end to our art
so speaking of endings you knew it would
culminate in this concert and seymour i
want to ask you you you haven't
performed in public and oh i don't want
to tell you about that well
well now ethan
we we ethan and his wife and i
had a meeting
in the same room where we met at dinner
he was sitting with his wife opposite
the table and i was sitting on this end
and he was telling me more or less
what the thesis would be of the movie
he wanted to show
as what i said before how a passion for
an art form
can influence your life and not just the
art form
now he pauses and he says to me
now seymour
you know i'm a member of a theater group
and now you don't have to say yes
but i have to ask you i know you haven't
performed in public for 37 years yes but
would you consider
giving a recital and speak about the
music to
the theater group because they don't
know very much about classical music
see the color of your paper
that's the color i turned
i re i felt all the blood leave my face
i said oh dear
going back to that nightmarish
situation
then and you know how one's mind works
in a flash
maybe a couple of seconds went by but to
me it seemed like minutes
and i remember thinking
what is he asking me to do this for
i know why
he wants to avoid people
pointing to this stupid old adage
that those who can do
and those who can't teach
right i thought of that immediately
and
this wonderful man i wasn't going to let
him down
you know he's going to make a
documentary on me
i said yes